では よろしくお願いします
それで このお釈迦様とこのスバという青年の間の対話で
まあお釈迦様はこのバラモン人の教えである五つの道徳
いわゆる善というのは何なのかということで
善を確立するために 道徳というものを確立するために
いわゆるまあ精神的に宗教的に考えてみると
まあ宗教の目的みたいなもんなんですね
で 確立するために五つの項目をまああるんだろうと言ったところで
お釈迦様はまあその通りやというふうな一言言わないで
まあ一つケチをつけるんですね
で まあ俗っぽくといえば
まあお釈迦様が言うことは
まあただ言っただけで意味がありませんと
いうぐらいだったら誰にでもできるんじゃないかと
何か言うならば それははっきりとその通りであると
それが正しいということは
やっぱり実験して実践して証拠を出さなきゃあかんかと
ただ理論だけではね 足りませんと
理論といったっても まあ仮説みたいなもんになっちゃうんですね
ただ 仮説だけではまあ話になりませんと
ちゃんと実践して それがその通りであるということを証拠を出さなくちゃいけないという
まあ仏教的な立場というか
釈尊の立場なんですね
ということは お釈迦様がおっしゃっているどんな言葉でも
すべてその通りであることは
まあ実践で証拠を積んでるんですね
そういうわけで その話を聞く我々にも信頼して実践できる
まあどうせ宗教の世界だから全部わかるわけないんですよ
なんだかんだでも 全部わかるんだったら
別に宗教なんか勉強する必要ないし
もう完全な人間だからね
だからわからないのは当たり前
もうたくさんあるんですよ
そうすると わからないことを信仰するかと
例えば神様がいるんだろうと言ったところで
それは人間にわからないのは当たり前なんですね
それだったらもう必ずしも信仰するということになってしまうんですね
で それがいけないと仏教でお釈迦様が言ってるんだからね
信仰はまあ二面性を持ってるんだと
信じていることはその通りかもしれませんし
あるいはまるっきり違うかもしれません
だから五分五分ではダメですよというふうなことになってしまうんですね
それでブッダの教えにしたっても
全部わかるわけないんですよ
お釈迦様が煩悩なくなった時の幸福感を喜びを語っている
で 煩悩をなくすこと 貪瞋痴を怒り
むさぼり 無知っていうのはもう完全に捨てることこそ幸福であると
何ものにもとらわれないことこそが幸福であると
財産やら妻子やら子供やら家族やらね
あることが面倒くさくて苦しみの種になるんだよと
そういうものに執着しない方がもう究極の幸せであると言っても
そんなのわかるわけないんですよ
財産が別になんでしょうか
別に悪いわけではないと
家族なんかはもう楽しいんじゃないかと
悪いわけじゃないっていうのは
まあ常識的なところなんですね
だから 怒りなんか捨てたら大丈夫かなとかね
欲なんか捨てて大丈夫かなというふうに
普通は人間というのは常識な人間だったら考える
それで その人は仏教通りになりたいと思うならば
やっぱり怒りは良くないと信仰するんですかね
信じるんですかね 輪廻は危険であると
解脱は究極な幸福であると信じることになっちゃうんですよ
で 信じてもいいというならば
もう他の宗教で言ってるように
神様を信じてもどうったことはないってことになるんですね
ですから この信じていいということをお釈迦様は認めませんね
その代わりに自分がおっしゃっていることは全部実践して
その通りであるとしっかりとなんに公で発表しているんですよ
こういうことは私がやってみて
体験して こういう結果になりましたよ
ですから たった一人の人間でもいいんだから
この教えを実践して 本当にその通りの結果になるかならないかということは
証拠を出してくれるんだったら
一人だけでも成功したならば
だったらその証拠に基づいて他の人もやればもうなるんではないかという
この可能性が成り立つんですね
全くできないわけではないんだと
やればできるんでしょうという可能性が成り立つんですね
ですから わからないのは当たり前で
わからなくても大丈夫だと信頼しなさいよ
だってちゃんとやった人々がいるんだから
やって証拠を出してる人々が
実証しているした人々いるんだから
あんた心配する必要ないんだよと
それで論理的に信じるんですよ
証拠に基づいて信じるんですね
いわゆる仏教でいう信仰は
やっぱり確信というか
このまあ可能性ですね
自分では実証してないんだけど
まあ考えてみれば もうその可能性あるんだよという確信なんです
ですから このお釈迦様がまあやっぱりやる前に自分がやったことないんだから
証拠はないはずなんでしょうし
自分で実証 例えば涅槃は究極な幸福であると分かった上で涅槃体験するっていうことはありえないことなんですよ
で これが世界一美味しい食べ物だと
ちゃんと自分で分かった上で
では試してみるぞっていうことにはなりません
試してみるということは
もう味わってないということなんですね
ですから これが世界一最高な美味しい食べ物やと自分で言う場合は
他の人々 誰か誰がそれ食べてみて試して言っている
そうすると あ だったらもしかするとこれは世界一最高の食べ物かもしれませんと
で 私も心配しないで一応食べてみると
疑うことをしないで 毒入ってるかわからないとかね
まずいかもしれませんとかね
そんなことはもう心配しない
何人か何人か言ってるんだから
これが最高の美味しいだと
美味しいんだと それなりの信頼できる人々が言っているんだから
遠慮しないで 心配しないで食べてみればいいっていうことになるんです
同じ理屈で仏教の論理もできているんですね
だからもう何でもわかってますよということはとんでもない嘘でわかるわけないんですね
やったことはないんだから
やったこともないし わかるもしないものは信じるというと
危険性はそのままなんですね
なんだかんだで無茶苦茶信じるもんじゃないんですね
信じるためにはそれなりのもう何かまあ証拠みたいなもの必要ですよ
そのポイントですね この青年にお釈迦様がこのもうきつく言ったのは
だから項目自体が別にお釈迦様が正しくないとは言いたくはないんです
ではもう一度項目を思い出してみますけど
サッチャ・タパ・ブラフマチャリア・アッジーサナ・チャーガ
サッチャは真理 タパは修行
ブラフマチャリアは欲から離れて道徳ですね
アッジーサナっていうのは学ぶこと
勉強することですね チャーガは布施ですね
その 5つはバラモン人がまあ理屈で作ったもんなんですね
考えて作ったもんですよ
論理的に作ったもんなんです
それがこのリストを見ると
私はこの前の説明しました
リスト見るとよく見えるんですよ
まあ誰でもやっぱり真理は知りたいと
真理こそがすごいとまず思ってしまうんですね
真理って って何なのかっていうことは別にまだわからないんだけど
やっぱり真理があるんだと
この真理がだから最高やとというふうにまず思ってしまう
それでそれを理解するためにどうすればよろしいかといえば
やっぱり修行しなくちゃいけないんですね
タパっていうのは それなりに苦労しなくちゃいけない
生半可な気持ちでできるわけじゃないんだということで
やっぱりタパスも必要だし
修行も まあ修行しようと思ったところで
欲に溺れて修行できるわけじゃないんですね
では道徳的なブラフマチャリア
戒律は全部ブラフマチャリアという一言葉にまとめているんですよ
で ブラフマチャリアっていうのは性的な行為をしないという意味なんですけど
簡単に言えば また言葉で文字通りに解釈をすると
このブラフマというね
神様の生き方なんですね
ブラフマという神様はもうすごい清らかで
何も汚れがない 何も汚れがない存在やというふうに思っているんですね
だからヒンドゥー教でもブラフマと神という二次元性をいくら考えていたんですけど
神っていうのはもう結構だらしないですね
ヒンドゥー教のヴィシュヌ神にしたっても
クリシュナにしたって
そいつらみんなだらしないんですよ
しかし ブラフマという言葉を使っちゃうと
そうじゃないんです だからシヴァにしたっても
もうとんでもない連中なんですね
もう何やるかもうわからないというかね
もうどんなくだらんことでもするする
ですから そこで同じヒンドゥー教でブラフマという考え方があります
ブラフマといったところで
全くもう優れていて そんなだらしないところはひとかけらもない完全なという状態なんですね
だからウィシュヌ神にもまた奥さんがいたり
シヴァにも何人かパールティやら何人かがいたり
それで嫉妬したり まあもうやりたい放題ですね
それは神という次元で考えると
ブラフマという次元で考えると
もう全く何もない 完璧ということになるんですね
ですから このブラフマの生き方はブラフマチャリアなんですね
そこは人間が真似をすると
ということで 一番最初にもう人間とのそういう性的な行為したり
そういう関係は全くしないと
それだけで全ての人間は平等に見られるんですね
自分の欲を満たしてくれる機械ではなくて
普通の人間で平等で見られる
そこからまた他の道徳を成し立つんですね
ですから インド宗教の道徳的な世界っていうのは
やっぱりブラフマチャリアから
性的な行為から離れるから始まるんです
でお釈迦様もそれがないと何一つも道徳はないんだよと
他のものもやっぱりそれが基本でなるというふうにも言ってるし
いわゆる全ての欲を認めたことになるんだよと
全ての執着を認めたことになるんだよと
といって また他のところで別なこともおっしゃってますけどね
嘘をつくんだったらね
全て道徳何一つもないんだよとも言ってるし
まあいろいろ言ってはいるんですけど
一応性的な行為に対して言ってるのは
まあ修行する人 出家する人は
まあそれはやってもいいということにしちゃうと
どんな欲でも認めたことですよ
だったら普通でいいんじゃないかと
ということになっちゃうんですね
それで修行しなくちゃいけないということになってくると
すぐに必然的にブラフマチャリアが道徳的な戒律みたいなものがついてくる
そんなものをするにしたっても
ちゃんと勉強していないと
ただやるぞと 何をやるんですかね
これから戒律守るぞと言ったら
何が戒律ですか？わからない
だからやっぱり勉強するっていうことが必要になっちゃうんですね
それからもうチャーガということで
いわゆる自分が得たものをみんなにも分けてあげるというかね
そういうことをしなくちゃいけないということで
ですからチャークがすごいんです
チャークするっていうことは
もう大変なことになる
例えば自分がその真理を発見したら
そこでそれをみんなにもその知恵を分けてあげるということだから
まあ最高のものになっちゃうんです
だからお釈迦様がその五すその中で一番大化になるもの
一番優れているものは何なのかと軽々く聞いたのは
この青年が知らない この五すはどうやって成り立ったかということ
この経典の経典の中でも見えてこないんです
お釈迦様だけ知ってるんで
これは昔のすごい昔の先生たちは
これ理屈で論理で考えたものだと
しかし しっかりした論理で間違いあるわけじゃないんです
でも試したことはない
ただ考えて言っただけ
だから順番つける時でも
そこら辺が何か問題があるんだぞということで
お釈迦様はそれを教えてるんですよ
物の順番つける時でも
そういうちゃんと経験ない人でないとそんなことできないんだと
だからお釈迦様はこの何か言う場合はいつでも順番つけるんですよ
このブッダつける順番っていうのはもう全く変えることはできない
で 変えられる場合も それもお釈迦様もまたちゃんと言うんですね
八正道にしたっても 四聖諦にしたっても
何から何までやっぱり順番があるんです
七覚支にしたっても順番があるんですよ
その順番がものすごく大事なんです
それは変えられません
一つ先に入れましょうとかね
できません なぜかって
そういうのを全部実践して体験して言ってることなんです
イエーミーブーゴーゴートマ
ブラームナパンチャ
ダンメパンニャペンディプニャッスキリヤエクサラッサラダナエチャーガンエッフェブラームナダンマンマハッファラタランパンニャペンディプニャッスキリヤエクサラッサラーラダナヤーティとい
うところから
で 釈尊 この五つの法を禅に至る方法
法としてブラマン人が語っていて
その中でチャーガン 布施が一番誰かになるんだよと
ページで番目の段だと
で チャーガが布施が誰かになるんだと
誰かっていうのはマハッファラタラン
最高な結果出すものであると言ってますよと
それでお釈迦様は反対に質問だと
タンキンマンニャシマーナバイダーニャタラッサブラームナッサマハヤンニョパッチュパッティトーアッサアタドゥエブラームナアーガッチェヨン
イッタンナーマスブラームナッサマハヤンニャンアヌバヴィッサマハティ
タッタエカッサブラームナッサエーワマスアホヴァタハンアハメーワラベイヤンバッタッゲアッガーサナンアッゴーダカンアッガピンダン
ナアニャーヨーブラームノーラベイヤンバッタッゲアッガーサナンアッゴーダカンアッガピンダンティ
ターナンコーパネータンマーナバヴィッジャティ
ヤンアニャーヨーブラームノーラベイヤンバッタッゲアッガーサナンアッゴーダカンアッガピンダン
ナソーブラームノーラベイヤンバッタッゲアッガーサナンアッゴーダカンアッガピンダン
アニャーヨーブラームノーラバティバッタッゲアッガーサナンアッゴーダカンアッガピンダン
ナアハンラバアンバッタッゲアッガーサナンアッゴーダカンアッガピンダンティイティ
ソークピトーホーティアナッタマノーイマッサパナマーナバブラームナー
キングリパーカンパンニャーペンティーティ
それで ブラマン人が布施と言っても
結局このウパニシャッドの人々が言ってるような真理を弟子たちに体験させようということではなくて
ただくだらないこのブラマン人がやっている儀式儀礼のことなんですね
いわゆるヤーガという儀式がありましたからね
もうたくさんブラマンたちを呼んで
食べ物を用意してあげて食べさせる
その時はものすごい大げさに儀式をやるんです
聖典をあげたりとかね
まあヴェーダ聖典をあげたりと
アジェスナっていうのはヴェーダ聖典をあげることに似合う言葉なんです
そこでお釈迦様が簡単なことであるブラフマンの家でマハヤンの大儀式が始まりましたとします
アタドゥエブラフマナアガッティヨン
その儀式に参加するためにブラマン人が二人が来る
その人々は何のために来るかというと
この何々さんのブラマン人の大儀式で
かなりご飯食べて食事をして帰ろうではないか
いろいろお布施をもらっちゃうし
お金もいろんなものもらうんですよ
ご飯だけではなくて そのブラマン人が自分にできるだけのことを集めてお布施するんです
そういうことだから 何かもらうんじゃないかなと思って来る
そこで この二人の中で一人がこういうことを言いますね
アホワタハメワラベイヤン
私だけいただければありがたいと
何ですかというと バッタッゲこの食事の時
アッガーサナ一番上の席
神座ですか もう一番上の席に私を座らせていただければありがたいと
それからアッゴーダカン一番最初に一番偉いブラモン人に水をあげるんですよ
で これもう我々インドでも同じかわからないんだけど
スリランカではその習慣ありますけど
人に水をあげるということは
この食事に接待するという意味なんです
ですから 水をもらった人は必ずしもその日でご飯食べなくちゃいけないんです
食べる気持ちなかったら水を断るんです
それはだいたいありえないんですけど
家に来ている人々だから
まあご飯台所で用意するし
それで用意ができたら
まあ奥さんの方はまあ旦那さんに用意できたよと言うんですね
そうすると旦那の方がちゃんと水を持っていって
そのお客さんに一人一人にあげる
やっぱりその時でも 先に誰に
もうガラスに水を入れてることだけですけど
お盆に入れて それを先に誰にあげるかということは
やっぱり考えないと やっぱり順番というのがありますからね
それでこのブラマンがこの私が神様に座らせて
このアッゲオーダが一番最初の水を私にくれるならば
それからアッゲピンダン最初のご飯の皿をね
最初に私にくれるならばありがたいと思っちゃうんですね
なんでそう思うかとそれはやっぱり徳が高いんですよ
立場もあるし もらうものもやっぱりちょっと違います
例えばいろいろお布施とかね
いろんな米やらお金やらもらうんだったら
一番上のところにはやっぱり割り当てが多いんです
そういうわけで一番上の席に座りたがる
そこでそう思うんだけど
タナンコーパナエタンマーナリッジャテしかし
こういうこともありえますよと
そのブラモンが全然もらわない
一番目の席はもらわない
神さは 他のブラモンがみんな集まるところで
誰が偉いかすぐわかっちゃいますから
もう集めてない 顔を合わせてないときは
やっぱり私もしかすると一番長老かもしれませんと
言ってみたら 自分よりは何人か年上のバラモンたちがいるかもしれませんし
そうすると もう何のことなく自分の立場が下へ行っちゃいますからね
他のブラモンがその立場がもらってしまいますね
そうするとそのブラモンがニ百五ページイティソウクピトホーティアナッタマノ
えらく怒るんですね 嫌になっちゃう
アナッタマナっていうのはすごく不機嫌になる
怒って不機嫌な気持ちになる
それで そういう時 どんな結果になるんですかと
いわゆる結果というか
得というかね その場合の得はいかがなものですかと
布施するんだから 何か結果を考えて布施するもんだからね
あなた方の世界ではそのケースはどういう結果にあるんでしょうかと説明していますかと
そこで青年が答える
ナケッタゴータマブラークマナエワンダーナンデンティイミナアパロクピトホーティアナッタマノティアタケッタブラークマナアヌカンパジャアティカンジェワダーナンデンティ
大沙門ナケッタと書いてるところをナコエッタという言葉は短くしているんです
ブラモンたちがこのようにお布施しているわけじゃない
このどのようにかてイミナアパロクピトホーティアナッタマノ
この布施によって他の受ける側が怒りますようにと
不機嫌になりますようにと期待して
みんな怒らせるために
不機嫌にさせるために
お布施しているわけじゃないんだと
アタケッタ バーマナ アヌカンパ
ジャーティカン まあ憐れみを持って
エーワ ダーナンデンティ
憐れみを持ってお布施しているんだと
いわゆるそれほど豊かでない貧しいバラモンたちに
ものすごいもうごっつり豊かなバラモンたちがいたんだからね
大金持ちで そういう人々は大きな儀式やるんですよ
その時は貧しいバラモンたちをみんな呼ぶ
ですから まあすごい憐れみを持って
まあお布施しているんだと
エヴァンサンテ コーマナバ
バーマナナン イダン チャッタン
プンニャ キリ エワット
ホーティ ヤディダン アヌカンパ
ジャーティカンティとお釈迦様にやられちゃいますね
だからこの憐れみを持ってお布施するんだと
だからお布施することがもう大変な善行為でということで言って
怒ったらどうしますか？誰かが
いや それは期待していないんだと
それは関係ないんだと
憐れみを持ってお布施しているんだと言われたら
お釈迦様 それだったら六番目もあるんじゃないの？と
善を満たすために六番目もあるんじゃないか
業ではなくて アヌカンパ・ジャーティと言われる憐れみという
他人に対して憐れみを持つこと
それも善ではないんですかと聞くんです
イエ
テーマナバ・ブラームナ・パンチャ・ダンメ・パンニャー・ペンディ・プンニャサ・キリアー・クサスラ・アーラダナヤ・イメー・トワン・パンチャ・ダンメ・カッタ
・バフラン・サムヌ・パッサシ・ガハッテ・スワ・パッバジッテ・スワと
そこで五つは大したことないってことになるんで
お釈迦様六番目もつけるんだから
それもお釈迦様つけるんじゃないんです
相手につけさせるんです
いとも簡単に ということは
布施よりは憐れみが一番上になっちゃう
順番で言えば布施が一番上でしょう
でお釈迦様六番目をつけちゃったんだから
お釈迦様が強引につけられた六番目は布施よりも上になってしまうんですね
というわけで バラモン人の教えがそれで壊れてしまうんですね
壊れるんだけど この壊し方が微妙なんですよ
否定しないで 道徳は否定しないで
道徳は守りながら このあなた方のやり方がまずいというところでね
いわゆる言ってるだけだと
真面目じゃないんだよというところだけ言ってるんですよ
例えばキリスト教の宗教から見ると
あの敵を愛しなさいと
汝敵を愛しなさいという
これは立派なことですよ
決して悪いことじゃない
だからキリスト教が偉いと言えるかと
先生偉いと言えないんですよ
キリスト教にとって何をやるかというと
敵を憎しむこと自体徹底的にやっているんですね
敵を許すという これは一度もやったことはない
歴史上も今も 敵を憎む
潰す お前らも参加しろと
という生き方なんですね
一度もなかったんですよ
歴史の中で だから立派な項目
言葉があるんだからといって評価するわけにはいきません
敵を愛することが決して悪いことじゃないんですよ
だから誰か一人でも 敵を愛して
敵を許してあげて それで素晴らしいんだよという証拠を出してくれないと
その証拠はないんですよ
どこにも イエスもその時はもうものすごく私を認めなかった連中はもう裁かれますよと
それ敵を愛することですかね
主を私を認めなかったということは先に潰ってくださいというのは正しいでしょうに
それがないんですよ だから言った本人もやってないんですね
ユダスに怒る ユダスに裏切れるように神がセッティングしていると堂々と自分が言って
だったら同じでしょうに
イエスも神の仕事を行ってるし
神がセッティングした仕事をユダスもちゃんと行って
その人かわいそうでしょうに
本当はイエスというのは人間のことをすごく愛していたんですよ
すごく大事で それなのに敵に紹介してあげなくちゃいけないことになったんだからね
その人の精神的な苦しみっていうのはね
並みじゃないでしょうに
だったらやっぱりね 同じ仕事してるんだからね
二人とも なんでその人に怒るんですかね
だから いや 結局は言ってるだけ
言っただけっていう ただ言ってみただけっていう感じなんで
だったら言うなよと これ言ってみただけだからね
いかに世の中大変でしょう
捨てられないし 頭が悪いんだからね
論理性に欠けてますから
みんな理性に 人間っていうのは
だから捨てるにも捨てられないし
認めるも認められませんし
だから敵を許してあげて
敵を愛して愛して それでいかに素晴らしい人間かという一人ぐらいでもいたならば
たった一人だけでもいたならば
その人のことを見てみんな頑張るでしょうに
だから一つの例がないっていうかね
だからみんな口だけでは
敵を愛して 行動では徹底的に潰すと
差別すると 排他的に考えると
イスラム教でもキリスト教でもそのちょっとこの欠点というのはまあ見えるんですね
同じことヒンドゥー教にしたっても確実にあるんですよ
やってもないのにペラペラペラペラ喋る
鳥のことやらあれやこれやよく喋るんですよ
まあこんなのはもう妄想ばっかりしてる連中にはいくらでもできることで
まあ頭もいろいろこと回転することだけだからね
みんな言葉に騙されて
まあ釣られてしまいます
だからお釈迦様は言葉についてもどう聞くべきかというところで
言語学というものもかすかに仏教の中でずっと進んでいるんです
ただ 美しい言葉だけでは意味がありませんと
言葉にそれなりの機能がなければ
ということで ものすごい言葉に対しても厳しいんですね
なぜかというと 人間はもういとも簡単に引っかかる罠は網は言葉なんです
それで 偽善な人に限ってものすごい綺麗に言葉喋られますよ
正直な人はそれほど言葉上手じゃないんですよ
だから人間っていうのはそんなにすっごい大胆ということじゃないんだから
自分が実際にやったことっていうのは
これこれぐらいのもんですよと
すごい謙虚で正直に言うんですよ
そうすると言葉が少ないんですよ
あまりにも大げさに喋るっていうのは
どうせ空っぽだからいくらでも喋られるんですね
それはどこいろんなケース見ると見えることだと思いますね
あれもやったこれもやったこれもやったあれもやったという人について
何一つもやってない 調べてみると
いろんなことをやった気になる人は
別にそこを全く大げさで言おうとはしない
まあ自分がまあ別にやってみたことだから
別にどうったことはないという
まあそんな大したことないんですよというふうな感じでいるんですね
だから人間というのは
どうしも美しい言葉にたくさん言葉を喋る人の罠にはもう網にはかかってしまいますね
ということだから 言葉には気をつけなくちゃいけないことになります
そこで この5番目に6番目も付けたことで道徳を壊さないで
言葉は嘘ではないんだから
問題は事実だと証拠を出してない
まあそこら辺はちゃんと理解してて
道徳はそのまま 無事守って
この人々の生き方がまずいんだよということを言うことになるんですよ
はっきりそう見えてく見えてこないんですけど
もうその方向なんですね
次の質問は そのあなた方いうこの五つの方はたくさん実践するのは誰ですかと Pabhajjitesu
bahulan samani passami
で 出家した人の間で見えますか？在家の人々の間で見えますかと
いわゆるこの五つの方をサッチャ
タパ ブラフマチャリア
アジェーサナ チャーガ
その五つの法を実践していて
いわゆるまあやっている
その人々がどちらの方が多いですかと
出家の間ですか 在家の間ですかと聞いたら
この人の答えはPabhajjitesu bahulan samani passami appan gahatesu
やっぱりその五つは出家する人々がよくやってますよと
在家の人々はあんまりやってないんだよと
で もうさらにこの弁解もする
その人は gahatto
hi kho braah gotama mahatto mahaaciccho mahaadhikarano mahasaamaaram bho
まあほとんどあの まあ同義語ですけどね gahatto
在家の人っていうのはゴータマ mahatto
まあアッタっていうのは悩み事多いというかね
そのやるべきこと 悩み事多いとか
まあそんなもんですね mahaaciccho
まあ仕事多い しなくちゃいけないこと
義務が多い 義務ですね mahaadhikarano adhikarana
っていうのは判断することですね
いろんな決断すること
あれやこれやと問題ですね
だから問題も多い 義務が多い
問題も多い mahaasaamaaram
bho だからもう大忙しい saamaaram aaram
っていうのは頑張ること
努力することです だから努力するもの
頑張らなくちゃことっていうのは
マハー たくさんあるということで
いわゆる大忙しっていうことなんですね Na
satataṃ samitaṃ sacchavaadii hoti
だからsatataṃ samitaṃ
いつでもsatataṃ samitaṃというのは二十四時間という意味なんです sacchavaadii
hoti 真理を語っているわけじゃないんだと
嘘も言わなくちゃいけないことになるんだよと
仕事が多い やることは多い
いろんな問題があるし
だからそのそのその都度
なんとかまあ事実でないものを言って言わなくちゃいけないんだと Pabhajito
kho pana bho gotama appatto appaciccho appaadhikarano appasaamaaram bho
それに反対に 出家は仕事は少ないし
やる判断することもほとんどないし
忙しくはないし satataṃ
samitaṃ sacchavaadii hoti
いつでも真理を語る人々
二十四時間 そこで同じことをちゃんと説明してくれるんですね
在家の人々は仕事が多いんだから na
satataṃ samitaṃ tapassi ho
修行はしない 二十四時間も
そこでこの一応経典でこのこの五つの真法の定義は来なかったんですね
ただ お釈迦様に五つの項目を言われただけ
お釈迦様はそれだけでもそれはちょっと潰しちゃったんですね
潰しちゃったんですけど
その五つの法はもう正しい道徳であるということは別に否定していない
しかし 仏教はただ言っただけで終わりませんから
定義もしないと この言葉の意味をはっきりと
人が勝手に解釈してはいけません
例えば私が言ったことは勝手に解釈すると全く違うことになるんですね
よくある現象です 随分勝手にすごい知ったかぶりで解釈する
そんなの成り立たない
本人が何を考えていたかということをその本人に聞かないと
だからそれはすごい真理を大事にする
誤解を嫌がる人々の性格で
誤解でありがたいと思う人は先生本人に聞かない
自分勝手に解釈するってことはするんですね
そういう人には勉強できません
それはまあ 一応昔からあの
まあちゃんと勉強する人の事実を知る人の生き方なんです
すぐ聞く これはどういう意味でしょうかと
どう理解すればよろしいかということに
だから考えたのは別の人だからね
それでこのこの五つの法について定義が来なかったんです
これでこのやっぱり定義ももうどんどん変わっちゃうんですよ
これでこの青年が自分でこう定義するんですよ
それでサッチャン真理ということは
この人のこの言った人の定義によると
嘘を言わないことなんです
別に真理を何か発見するという意味ではないんですね
でもサッチャンだけになっちゃうとすごい曖昧で真理そのものになっちゃうんです
だからいかに言葉定義しないで意味が変わるかと
だから私は最初はわざと真理というふうに定義しておいて
それは自分勝手な定義で
真理という言葉の定義で
そこで実際その言葉を使ったこのスバさんが自分で定義すると何になってるかというと
嘘言うななかれというぐらいのことになっちゃうんです
それはサッチャン真理事実
だからサッチャはトゥルースというふうに訳もしますから
トゥルースといえば真
真理でしょう 事実でしょう
しかし 取り方がえらい違うんですよ
嘘言うなよということと
真理を発見するそうということ
ずいぶん違うんだ だからそれでこの定義しなきゃいかに変わるかということはわかると思います
それで在家の人々はあまりにも忙しいんだから
サッチャンタパッシーホーと
ずっともう修行はしない
ブラフマチャーリーホーと
道徳もいわゆる性的な行為も
もうきちんとやめますということは
在家の人々には無理ですと
サッジャエバウローホーと
そこでアッジェーサナンというのはサッジャエナということになっちゃうんですね
アッジェーサナは本当に勉強することなんで
こちらはこのもう上座部仏教に唱えることなんですね
サッジャエナといえば
ただ仏教で言えば経典を挙げることですね
儀式的に そんなのはできないんだと
チャーガバウロー 布施もできないんだと
たくさんできない 大きくできない
まあたまたまやるんだけど
ずっとできるわけじゃない
大量にできるわけじゃないんだと
パッバジトーコーパナボーコと
出家はそうじゃなくて
仕事はあまりないんだから
サタタンサメタン 24時間もタパッセイ修行中であるし
ダッマチャーリーもう欲的な行為をしていないし
サッジャエバウローいつでも経典をあげたりしているし
チャーガバウローよく布施もしているんだよ
そこでお釈迦様にお釈迦様はこのバラモンたちが言ってるこの五つの法は
やっぱりパッバジテーすバウランサマヌパッサーミアッバンガハッテーす
私が出家の人々はちゃんと実践しているんだと思いますよ
で 在家の人々はすごく少ないんだよと
そこでこの経典はどんなポイントで始まったかというと
それもとっくに崩れているんです
経典を始めたのは在家の方がすごいと
出家はろくでもないんだと
だってやることもないし
だから出家の道徳はそんな大したことはない
在家の道徳はすごいもんやというスバさんの奔走ですよ
それでお釈迦様はあなたの道徳なんか大したことないんだと
出家だから 我々在家の人々はものすごい忙しいなのに頑張ってるんだからすごいぞということは
この言った本人が崩るんで
お釈迦様ではないんです
言った本人がもう何のもう忘れてるんで
前の論点は お釈迦様は何に何をもって喧嘩したか
もうとっくに忘れて堂々と言うんだよ
それはもう出家が守ってるんだよと
バラモン人がおっしゃってる道徳
道徳が出家が守ってるんだ
それはやってないんだよと自分が言うんです
一応それで話終了なんですよ
もう完璧に負けて もう終わり
もう何一つも反論できない
だからそのお釈迦様のこの対話方法の一つ
その中でまあ知恵ある人にはそれをうまく使いますよ
だから自分の意見出して
人の意見間違ってるというよりは
言った人の意見で言った人に言わせた方が一番いい対話方法なんですね
それでもどうにもならない
怒りも出てこない どちらにでも
お釈迦様は別に人を侮辱したことになりませんし
負けた人も自分で認めるんだから
別にどうったことないですね
この経典のポイント 大事なところはそこら辺
大事というよりはね あまり見えないところ
隠れてるところを私はどんどんどんどん出してます
だからそれは学者は決して出さないんです
言葉通りにあるポイント言うだけで
ですから この言葉の裏にあるお釈迦様がこういうことなんです
すごく優しくて しかしものすごく鋭くて
もう何から何まできちんと把握していて
しかし爪は見せません
軽々とこの相手をちゃんと道に道案内する
だから誹謗中傷ひとかけらもない
非難 他宗教非難とか全くもない
しかし 真理はこういうものだよという
あまりにももう人間にできない
ものすごい難しいことですよ
やってる 堂々とお前間違ってるんだよというのは
そんなどんなバカにも言えるんですからね
誰でもそう思ってるんだから
自分以外みんな間違ってるんだと
そんなのはもう別にどうったことはないんです
言ったっても だから真理を知って
どちら真理そのものを知ってから
どちらが間違ってるかと
それは自然に現れるようにするっていうことがね
大変なことですよ だから内容はもう単純ってわけじゃないんです
この経典は こういう風に理解してみると
ブッダのブッダは本当にブッダというそのその方を見えてくるんですよ
そう たいそうなんですよ
なかなかもうそのような知恵のある人っていうのは
やっぱり未だにいろんな本がありますからね
どこにでも見えますね
残念なことは もう誰しもそれをもう表に出そうとはしない
表に出す余裕ないんで
それより内容の方がもっとたくさんありすぎて
一生かけてもブッダの仏教の内容を勉強したっていうももう終わらないんだから
みんなそこら辺で途中で死んじゃいますよ
みんな終わらないまんまで
だからブッダそのものを出しても
ということはまあそう簡単ではない
それで相手がもう自分で認めたんだから
自分が持ってきた問題で自分でそれ間違いだと
それからお釈迦様は自分の説法するんです
それからあの 205 ページの最後のところ
イエ
ーテーマーンナブラームナパンチャダンメパンニャペンティプンニャッスキリアエクサラッサラーラダナエチッタッサハンエーテーパリッカーレーヴァダーンガリダン
チッタンアヴェーランアッリャパッジャンタッサバーワナーレ
青年よ バラモンたちがパンチャダンメパンニャペンティ
5つの法を設定していますと
プンニャッスキリアエ
徳を積むためにね クサラサラーラダナエ
まあうなずく その 5つの法は心のチッタッセ・パリッカーレ
心のパリッカーレであると私が言いますよ
だからこの場合はお釈迦様の考え方ということをはっきりするんですね
アハンヴァダアミ 私が言いますと
パリッカーラといって何なのかと
パリッカーラはまあまあ一応必需品という意味なんですね
で まあ駅までね まあ例えば 1KMぐらいあるんだったら
まあ自転車使うとかね
人間パリッカーラっていうのはやっぱりそういう必需品のこと で
まあそれがあった方が便利
ない方がなんとか困る
例えばご飯は炊いたんですけど
もうお皿も茶碗もないんだったら食べる時は困りますね
その釜でそのままもう食べられないわけないんですけど
やっぱり他の何があった方がいいっていうことになりますし
文字を書きたいんだけど
鉛筆もボールペンもないと言ったら
やっぱりそれで困りますしね
そうやってこのカバンやら服やら傘やら草履やら
まあいろいろそういうものにもパリッカーラで言うんですよ
人の服もパリッカーラで
まあ履物もパリッカーラで
もう持ってるカバンやら家にある道具やら
まあ全部パリッカーラなんですね
必需品 それで楽に生活できるということに
ということで まあパリッカーラ道具ばっかし集めると
で 楽が消えてしまうんですね
現代はもう逆にまあ道具のために生きてる生き方になってるんですね
だから昔からお釈迦様はパリッカーラというものはもう最小限にしておかないと
自分の立場がなくなっちゃうんですね
マスターである自分がとても簡単に奴隷になっちゃうんです
例えば人が車買うといえば
それは一つのパリッカーラですけどね
問題はないんですよ それにしたら
まあポルシェやらロールスロイスやら
そういうバカでかいリムジンとかね
買ってしまうと もう動けなくなっちゃうんですね
使えなくなっちゃうんです
それでそのリムジンに合わせて自分が生活しなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
それがやっぱりやりすぎ
だから道具っていうのは必要なんですけど
もうあまり揃ってしまうと効き目が弱になると
そこでお釈迦様が心にも必需品があるんだ
必要な道具があるんだよ
だから君が言ってるこの 5つは心の必需品だよ
全くお釈迦様が意味を変えるんですよ
だからお釈迦様にしてみれば
心を育てることが善であって
宗教の仕事であって こんなものじゃないんだよと
この 5つなんかはね そんなのは道具だよと
その道具を使って正しく使用すると心が成長していくんだよと
食べる時はお箸があったら食べられるし
しかしお箸そのものがすごい大したもんだよという必要はないんですね
ただ一つの道具であって
うまく使えば食べられると
心の道具ですよ 何のために
ヤリダンチッタンアヴェーランアッリャパッジャンタッサバーワナーレ
心アヴェーラン 怒りなく
憎しみなく いわゆる慈しみの心を育てるために
お釈迦様がすごく好きな言葉というか
よく使う言葉アヴェーランアッリャパッジャン
何の怒りも何の憎しみもない心
何に対して だからかすかにでも心の嫌な気持ちも憎しみも怒りも何もない心がいいと
それが宗教が語るべき心ですよと
だから敵やら悪魔やらあれやこれやとかね
まあ異教徒やらね そういう概念なんかは
まあできてないろくでもない人間作る概念ではなくて
何の怒りも憎しみも何一つもない心を育てましょうと
だからその言葉から見ると
敵を愛しなさいとかね
大して意味がないんですよ
そんな立派な言葉じゃないんですよ
ここ こういったこの言葉から
それに合わせてお釈迦様というのは心がアベーラ・ガッベーア・パリータ
怒り憎しみ全くないきれいな心を作ろうと
それは自分の仕事だから
タッサ・バーハナへ それを実践するために
これが道具ですよと その一つが
怒り憎しみのない心を育てる
実践するために育てるための道具
そこで道具の説明に行きます
イダ
・マナワ・ビクク・サッチャワーディー・ホーティ・ソー・サッチャワーディー・ミーヒティ・ラバティ・アッタ・ウェダン・ラバティ・ダンマ・ウェダン・ラバティ・ダンモーパ・サンヒタン・パームッジャン
イダ・マナワ ここでビクが修行者がサッチャワーディー・ホーティ・サッチャワーディー
すごい真理を語る人になる
事実を語る人になる ソー
彼がサッチャワーディー・ミーヒティ
私は事実を語る人やと
嘘言わない人やと ラバティ・アッタ・ウェダン
それでまあアッタ・ウェダンっていうのは
まあまあ充実感感じるっていうことかな
まあなかなか捨てたもんじゃないんだと
自分はもう真理を語る人である
事実を語る人である 嘘は言わない性格やということで
何か自分に対して何かまあなかなか捨てたもんじゃないという気持ちになるんですよ
自分が 自分のこと ラバティ・ダンマ・ウェダン
ダンマというのは真理ということで
まあこれが正しいという
私は正しい生き方をしているんだと
間違っていない生き方をしているんだというふうな
なんとなくまあ充実感というものを感じる
ラバティ・ダンモーパ・サンヒタン・パームッジャン
それでダンモーパ・サンヒタン
この良いこと 正しいこと
真理ですね ダンマ 法ですね
その真理 法によって生まれてくるパームッジャン
喜びが生まれてくるんだと
だから真理語る嘘を言わない人がそれによって喜ぶと
自分がもう充実している
捨てたもんではありませんと
何か意味のあることをやってるんだと
よかったと それで私というものは
まあまあ結構よく頑張っているんではないかという喜びを感じるようになるんだと
ヤンタン・クサルーパ・サンヒタン・パームッジャン
それでクサルーパ・サンヒタン・パームッジャン
この良いことをしてから生まれてくるこの喜びが
まあ喜びというか充実感
よろしいと思いますけど
すごい充実感があって喜びが感じる
その喜びがそれもチッタセータンパリカーランワダン
心のもう一つの道具ですよ
やっぱり喜ばないと心が成長しないんですよ
だから嫌々やることでは
逆に心には悪い結果になるんですね
やっぱり喜びながら 充実感を感じながらいいことやってるんだよという
あの楽しみを感じながら活動しないと心は成長しない
ですから この喜びも一つ心の必需品だよ
道具ですよ それでも続けていくんですよ
5つも道具であって お釈迦様がこの憐れみというものも
あんた方 6番目につけることになるんだぞと言ってからかっただけで
それを置いといて でお釈迦様はもう一つ続けるんですよ
心の道具 6番目パーモッジャンという喜びを感じる
その喜びを感じることのアヴェランアッビアパッジャンという清らかな心育てるための道具になるんだよと
そこでイダマノビククタパッシーホーティブラマチャーリーホーティサッジャエバフロホーティチャガバフロホーティ
他の 4つも同じ順番で説明していくんですね
それでそうチャガバフルーミーとラバティアッタヴェダン
私はいつでも人にものを与えてあげる
ものは自分で持てない
まあまあどうぞどうぞ持っていってください
持ってものはよく布施する人やと
それでラバティアッタヴェダン
自分の人生は捨てたものじゃないんだと
何か意味があるんだよと
人にものを与えたり 助けてあげたりしているんだから
ただ空しい生き方ではないんだよということで
充実感が出てくる それによって良いことをしているんだからね
それによって喜びが なかなかまあ頑張っているのではないかと
自分なりには ということで喜びを感じる
私なりにはちゃんとやってるつもりですよ
それは他人に言うと嘘になっちゃうんですね
他人に言いたくてやってるものはほとんど偽善になります
だから 自分で自分のことを観察すると
なかなか頑張って生きてるんではないかと
それが本物なんです 私は頑張ってるんだよ
人にいろんなものをあげますよとかね
言うんだったら全然喜び感じてないんですよ
虚しいんです 心は育っていないんです
ではなくて 一人で一体全体
私の人生って何なのかと考えれば
私は全然嘘をつく性格で
なかなか捨てたもんじゃないと
修行もいろいろしているし
捨てた捨てたもんじゃないと
道徳も守っているでしょうしな
捨てたもんじゃないと
お経あげたり いろんなことを勉強したりもするし
それで人を助けてあげたり
お布施したりもして 結構頑張ってるんじゃないかと
自分なりには というのは本物の喜びなんですね
そういう喜びが道具です
結局は それでお釈迦様はそんなに大かっちり入れてるわけじゃないんです
その喜びさえも充実感の道具だよと
何のためにアヴェーランアッビアパッジャン
それを育てるため いわゆる完全たる平和な心
誰にでもぶつからない
対立しない 何に対しても対立は起こらない
完全たる平安な平和な心を育てるための道具ですよ
だから道具であることを忘れてはいけません
それはちょっと現代社会ではちょっとわかりにくい
道具の方が人よりも大事ですね
だから 服に合わせて体を調整する世界だからね
すごい高価なカバンとかあるんですけど
物は入りません ただ見せるだけのね
それはもう本当にもうイカれた生き方なんですよ
イカれた生き方にはこの地球は持てませんね
なんか一人なんかこの国会のレポーターですかね
なんかあの国債がね 30兆円もまあ超えたっていうことについて何かしゃべって
やっぱりまあ全部もう空っぽで虚しいよと言ってることもなんだかんだで
もうどんな何やってもうまくいかないんだと
それはまあ私たちは今このままの無駄な生き方をね
ずっと維持しようとしているんだから
まあこれから見込みがないんだよというふうな一言言ったんですね
やっぱりこの一言はもうサッと言っただけで
まあ何か正しい意見言ってはいけない世界だから
で それでまあ消えちゃったんですけど
やっぱり私はあの 1行には事実があるんだよと
だからこの無駄なもうもう虚しい
この生き方そのまんま守ろうとしていて
作ってるこの改革だから
何一つもうまくいかないんですね
だから言ったことを約束は一つも守ってくれないんですね
無駄をなくそうと言って
いえ それはできませんと道路建設を
いえ それはできませんよとかね
だったらそのまんまでものすごいお金がね
もう 100円でできることには
やっぱり 100万使うそうと
何のためですかね それで経済って成り立つわけじゃないですもん
だから先進国の一番下に落ちてしまったというかね
やっぱりこの現代人には理解できないんですね
やっぱり見栄を張った方が正しいと
飢え死になってもという生き方になっているんですね
だから道具に対しては
道具は道具であることは決して忘れてはいけない
それがもう現代社会が
この文明社会が これが忘れちゃったんですよ
だから原子爆弾まで現れてくる
科学兵器まで現れて 道具は道具であると
人間の奴隷であると それより人間の方が偉いということを
ただ自分が作った道具でしょうに
なんで道具のためにそんなに奴隷になるんですかね
あんまりにも屁理屈 だからそこはお釈迦様が昔から注意しているところなんですね
で だから出家にはもうすごい厳しい
いらんものはもう使ってはいけません
で それでそこは物質的なところで
お釈迦様はそこまでじゃなくて
精神的な世界でも道具論を持ってくるんですよ
そうすると精神世界でもものすごい間違いがあるんですよ
どんな宗教を見ても 儀式はすごい偉くて
先祖やら神様やら作り上げて
それだけものすごく偉くてとかね
結局人間は奴隷扱いになってるんですね
あなたはどうでもいいと
こういう式だり こういう習慣
それやりなさいというふうなところになっているんですね
だからこの生き方というのはすごい苦しいんですよ
例えば あるお寺があって
そのお寺に何か決まりがあったりとかね
で 例えば不動さんを本尊にして拝んでるんだろうと
これたとえくだらん醜いとわかっても捨てるわけにいけなくなっちゃうし
あるお寺に行ってみたところで
閻魔大王様を拝んでるんですね
すごい大きい像を造って
もう閻魔大王 仏ではないんですね
で そんなやつらがいるかと聞いたって
もし研究したところでもういないとわかったっても
もうしょうがなくて 嫌で嫌ででもそういう式だり
習慣 くだらんものは何の役にも立たないものでも守らなくちゃいけなくなって
それがやっぱり道具にやられているっていうことなんです
そんなのは道具であると
だから用がなくなったら捨てろと
割り箸と同じだから 別に割り箸は悪くはないんですよ
ご飯食べたらそのまま燃えるゴミに捨てるんでしょうに
これが私はもう 2002年11月7日に
食べた割り箸ですよとちゃんと置いておくとかね
それで家だらけで割り箸でもいる人にいるところはなくなっちゃうんですね
じゃあ捨てますと 冗談じゃない
私は四十年も集めたものですよ
っていうことになっちゃうんですね
そういうのは精神的に明らかに仏教から見れば病気ですよ
この収集家やらね だからこの宗教の世界
精神の世界でも まあこの道具にやられています
だからまあ全部決まり
決まり 決まりがあって
まあお寺建てるんだったらこんな風でなければあかん
こんな風でなければあかん
お釈迦様時代で まあそんなのはどうでもいいっていうことで
まあ心軽やかにしなさいよ
道具に過ぎないんだよっていうすごい現代的な立場ですね
現代的でいいないんか
そういう立場なんですね
だから私は平気で仏像は用が済んだら壊す
みんなその触りたくないとも
まあちょっと耳がもう折れちゃったんですけど
この間なんとかもう片付け時はもうこの仏像どうしましょうか
はいはい もうこっちの私のところに持ってきてくださいと
言って まあ本人がすごくすごく丁寧になんとかしきたりを踏んで
あの処分するだろうと
全然何のしきたりもない
そのまま潰して捨てる
用が済んだんだから もう言わんと
そこはすごく穏やかな気持ちになるならば
まあお釈迦様を思い浮かぶならば
まあそれを仕事してるんですよ
仏像は まあ考古学的に価値あるものは
これはまあ別な話ですけどね
それはまあ私人の人間の財産だから
それを守るのはね そんなに大したことはないしね
まあそういう博物館やらね
そういうところでみんなの財産で守っているものだから
個人個人が負担があるわけじゃないし
で それは別なんですけど
だからすごく大事なポイントっていうのは
この精神世界にしても
心育てる世界にしても
道具っていうものはあるんだよと
だから道具は道具でちゃんと理解しなきゃいけない
それにもまた一段階お釈迦様は進んでいて
お釈迦様が言ってる道具っていうのは
お数珠とかね そんなくだらないものではないんですよ
布施 真理を語ること 修行すること
戒律守ることなどなどなんですよ
もう写経とかそんなもんじゃないんです
お札やら数珠やらね でなんか何かあの鳴らすやつなんて言いますか
この信号で使ってる四本の足があって
上あのテレフォンってこうやってチリンチリンと鳴らすものありますね
うん それはすごい決まりあります
作りでも 密教でよく使うんですね
だから四本の足がこうやってつけて
そこで取っ手があって
そこでチリンチリンと鳴る
これはまあこれですね
そういうものやらそんなのはもう仏教全く関係ない世界でね
まあそうやって物質的な道具
精神世界に入ってますけどね
お釈迦様が言ってるのは物質的な道具ではないんですよ
精神的な道具なんです
お布施って何なのか これは大事ですよ
道具だから お布施でなきゃ心の怒りが憎しみが消えませんと
それは怒り憎しみない心を育てるための道具ですよ
それも順番があって お布施する人は充実感を感じて
喜びを感じて まあ我ながら捨てたもんじゃないんだよと
いいことをしているのではないかというところで
もうそれが怒り憎しみのない心を育てるための支えになるんだよ
で まあもうこれからこの青年がおとなしくブッダの話を聞く
もうだからこのポイントですね
ブッダのポイントは 今までやったのは
もうこの対話のレポートで
この道具であるという一言葉
お釈迦様のお言葉ですね
もう大人しく話を聞くと
これになっちゃったんです
このスバ青年がブラフマン人で
自分の宗教で最高にありがたいことだと思っているのは
梵が居る状態なんですね
ブラフマと一緒になること
で この釈尊に会ったバラモンたちがブラフマっていうのはやっぱり人格で取っているんですね
で 後でこの人格ではなくて
ブラフマンという中性名詞
中性名詞で言うんですか
ニュートラルで中性名詞でこの取っていたんですね
まあどちらでも別にブッダには大したことはないんですね
どんな言葉変えただけで
まあそれより分かりやすいブラフマって神様と一緒になると
キリスト教と同じで 個人でイスラム教徒も同じ
神様の愛すっていう感じでね
で 一緒になると それでお釈迦様がブラフマと一緒にいる方法なる方法を知っていると
ブラマン人は知らないんですよ
自分の宗教の目的に達する方法
私が聞いたことはあります
釈迦尊がこの梵我一如の方法を知ってるんだよと
でお釈迦様は答える はい
そうですよと答えませんね
そこら辺はブッダの知恵なんですよ
タンキンマンニャシマナワ アサンネ イトウ ナラカーラ ガモ ナイトウ ドゥーレ ナラカーラ ガモ
あんたどう思いますか？このナラカーラ村はアーサンナ
近いでしょうと ね イトウ ドゥーレ
ここからそんな遠くはないんではないんですか
ナラカーラ・ガーマという村は
ガーマは村ということで
ナラカーラっていうのは
まあ竹の職人というぐらいかな
エワン ボ アサンネ イトウ ナラカーラ ガモ ナイトウ ドゥーレ ナラカーラ ガモ
その通りです ナラカーラ・ガーマはまあそれほど遠くない
近いんですよ タンキンマンニャシマナワ イダッサ プリソウ ナラカーラ ガメ ジャーティワッドド カメナン ナラカーラ ガーマ ト
タワデーヴァ アワサタン
ナラカーラ ガーマッサ マッガン プッチェイユン
シヤアヌコ
マーナワ タッサ プリサッサ ナラカーラ ガーメ ジャータワッダッサ ナラカーラ ガーマッサ マッガン プッタッサ
ダンダーイタッタン ワー ヴィッダーイタッタン ワーテ
それであんたどう思いますか？イダ アッサ プリソウ
ある人がナラカーラ・ガーメ・ジャーティワッドド
ナラカーラ村で生まれ育て
カメナン ナラカーラ・ガーマ ト タワデーヴァ アワサタン
それがナラカーラ村から外へ出たところで
ナラカーラ・ガーマッサ・マッガン・プッチェイユン
誰かが彼にナラカーラ村に行く道を訊く
ナラカーラ村で生まれ
育てて大きくなった人がちょっと用事があって出ていく
自分の家から外へ外に出ていたところで
村を離れたところで誰かが来て
ナラカーラ村に行く道知ってますか？とその人に聞くんです
シヤアヌコ マーナワ タッサ プリサッサ ナラカーラ・ガーメ・ジャーティワッドド ナラカーラ・ガーマッサ・マッガン・プッタッサ ダンダーイタッタン
ダンダーイタッタン 残りは繰り返しだから
そのナラカーラ村人に道が聞かれてダンダーイタッタン
あれということになりますか
ダンダっていうのは鈍くなる
心が動かなくなる 我々
何か知らないことをいきなり聞いたら
あれ？ということになるでしょうね
心が止まっちゃうんですよ
すぐ答えが出てこないと
例えば誰かの電話を聞いたところで
すぐ心が止まるんですね
その時のダンダーイタッタンというのは引っかかるという
ヴィッダーイタッタン
いわゆる緊張して心配するところなんですね
ヴィッタイタっていうのは
ワーティ で まあ例えば皆様に外国人のここら辺もいろいろいるんですけど
英語でこの幡ヶ谷駅に道どう行けばよろしいですか？と聞いちゃうとどうなるんですかと
英語で聞かれちゃうと
まあやっぱり英語を喋らない人だったらいきなりもう心が止まってしまっちゃうし
それ大事じゃなくて ちょっと緊張してしまっちゃうんですね
そこでナラカーラ村人にナラカーラ村からも離れて
ちょっと外を出ているんですか？その人にナラカーラ村へ行く道聞いたら
その人は心が止まったり
ちょっと混乱したり 緊張したりでもしますかと
だからノーヒダン ボーゴーとも
いえ そんなことはないんだよと
タンキッセーヘトーアムヒボーゴーとも
プリソナラカーラガーメジャーティワッド
なぜならば その人がそのナラカーラ村に生まれ育った人ですよ
タッササバーワメーワナラカーラガーマスマッガンツビディターニ
彼にはサバーワメーワ
まあ必然的に当然もう当たり前で
もう自分ももう自分の村に戻る道
自分の家に戻る道だからね
そんなのは知ってるんだよとも
忘れるわけにも何もない
スヤーヌコーマーナワタッサプリッセナラカーラガーメジャーティワッドナラカーラガーマスマッガンブッダッセ
ダンダイタッタンワヴィッタイタッタンワ
それでもお釈迦様は言いますよ
でもありますよ それでも
ナラカーラ村に生まれ育った人がちょっと村から出たところで
誰かに道聞かれたら やっぱりちょっと戸惑うっていうことはあり得るんだよと
で 青年がいえ こんなことはありませんと言います
お釈迦様 それでもあり得る可能性ありますよと
でも九十九点九九パーセントその人は何のことなく道案内できるはずなんですよ
ですから それでもお釈迦様が
それでもその人はちょっともしがすると
聞かれた人いたらちょっと何とかなる可能性ありますよということを言ってるんです
ナトゥエーワタタハガタッサ
しかし 如来にはそんなことさえもないんだよと
はいではなくても このはいの十倍にしているんですよ
梵我一如の方法を知ってますけど
はい 知ってます それじゃないんですよ
お釈迦様は はいの十倍にして答えているんです
だからいかにしっかり知ってるんですかと
この強烈に言うんですよ
それでだからはいだけでは済まないんですよ
どれほど明確に知ってるかということを強調するのです
ブラフマローカンワブラフマローカガーミニンワパティパダンプッタッサダンダイタッタンワヴィッタイタッタンワ
ブラフマローカ ブラフマの世界
あるいはブラフマの世界に行く方法
生まれ変わる方法 聞かれたらちょっと戸惑うとかね
ちょっと困ったなということはありえないんだと
如来には ブラフマナンチャハンマーノパジャナーミ
この梵天たち 私はよく知ってますよと
この梵天にいるその人々は知ってますよと
よく ブラフマローカンって
その梵界ですか 梵天界
その世界も知ってますよ
ブラフマローカガーミニンチェパティパダン
そこでどうすれば生まれ変われるかと
それも知ってますよと
どのように修行すれば
ヤタパティパーンノー
どのように修行すれば梵天界に生まれ変われましたかと
人々はね パンチャパジャナ
それも知ってますよ だから行く道知ってるだけではなくて
あの人はこのような修行して
今はそこに生まれ変わっている
あの人はこのように修行して
ここに生まれ変わっている
この人がこのような修行してここに生まれ変わっているって
そこをケースバイケースでも知ってますよ
ただ このように修行すれば梵天に生まれ変わりますよというだけじゃないんですよ
実例で 梵天たちの一人一人のケースバイケースでも言えますよ
みんな知ってますよ その世界もその世界にいる連中もみんな知ってますよ
それだけじゃなくて 一人一人がどんな修行して生まれ変わったかと
ケースバイケースでも知ってます
知りすぎ [笑い]そこで最初の質問をお釈迦様は知ってるんだよということなんです
言ったらお釈迦様はもうはいは二倍にして答えたんです
でも道は言わない この青年
なぜならば 質問が知ってますかということだから
それ以上は言わない それでスタメタンボーゴーとも
それでまた青年が負けちゃうんですね
私は聞いたことがあります
サマノーゴーとも ブラフマナンサハベターイマッガンデーシエーティ
お釈迦様はこの梵我一如のために方法
説法もすると聞いたことがありますよと
方法を教えると聞いたことがあります
知ってると聞いたことあります
前の質問 今度は方法を教えてるんだと聞いたことありますよと
だからその中でもお釈迦様はこの微妙に話を持っていくこと
余計なことは一言葉も言わない
ちゃんと質問に答えて
そこできちっと止まると
そういうあらゆる性格見えるんですよ
ずっと今までの流れで
あまりにも複雑ですよ
ブッダっていうのは 単純には理解できるものじゃない
まあどうせ人間には理解できないということになってますけどね
だから教えると聞いたことあるんだったら
お釈迦様丁寧今の素直にだったら聞きなさいと
サードカンマですから
よく理解しなさい バーシシャさんこれから喋りますと
喋りなさいと言われたんだから喋りますと
で 彼もエーワンボーティスボーマーのトーディーグッドバグとバッチャス
お釈迦様に答えて バグは得た道とお釈迦様はこのように喋ります
カトモーチマーノブラフマナンサハヴィターエマッゴー
梵我一如の道は何なのかと
イダマーノビックーメッッターサハガティーニチェータサエーカンディサンパリットワーヴィハラティ
それで修行法いろいろあるんですよ
ケースバイケースでも知ってます
しかし お釈迦様が推薦するのはこれなんです
ブッダにしてみれば もう梵我一如やらくだらんことになったって
輪廻そのものだからね
あまり推薦したくないんですよ
これやりなさいと でもどうしても行きたいというならば
それさせてあげないと
失礼でしょうに 例えば人が子供がね
まあ雪が降ってて寒いのに
もう風邪も引いてるのに
どうしても雪遊びしたいしたいというならば
やめろというのは普通ですけど
お前風邪引いてるでしょうと
しかし どうしてもやりたいやりたいで言っちゃうと
親の仕事っていうのはもう厚い服をいくつかいくつか着させてあげて
頭にも帽子をかかせてあげて
手袋もはめてあげて じゃあ行けと
しょうがないんですよ
だからもう安全にもう危険な内容に遊ばせてあげることしかないんですね
それでお釈迦様がこの方法を教えるんですね
イダマーノビックー これで比丘一人がメッッターサハガティーニチェータサ
メッター マイトリ 慈悲ですね
まあ慈悲と言ったってメッターっていうのは友情ですね
すべての生命も自分も同じ仲間という友情的な気持ちを育てて
エーカンディサンパリットワー
一つの方向 この方向は無限大まで全ての生命と私は一緒に仲間だよという気持ちで
この気持ちを育てる タタードゥティヤン
それから二番目の方向
タタートティヤン 三番目の方向
タタータチュッタン 四つのいわゆるあの前と後と右と左という四つの方向にして
無限にまで 全ての生命が私の前に生きている一切の生命と私も同じ仲間ですよ
同じ仲間だよと で 私の右側に住んでいる全ての生命が私としては同じ仲間だよと
その気持ちを実際に心の中で育ててみるんです
それで終わらない ウッダマドゥティリヤン
上 下 自分の上にも生命がいるんだから
自分の下にも生命がいるんだから
それからティリヤン ティリヤンっていうのはこの横ですね
いわゆるここに座ってる人がいて
肉がいて その人の前 後ろ
左 右 上 下つっぺってまとめて
あらゆる全ての方向にいる
あらゆる生命に対して無料で無限でメッターを育てている
マイトレイを育てている
慈しみを育てている いわゆるメッターだから
もう友人であると 友情であると
仲間だよという気持ちを育てている
イティ ユッダ マドゥ ティリヤン サッバディ サッバッタターヤ
全ての方向へ あらゆる至る所にサッバワンタン
一切を包囲してローカン
全ての世界をもう何一つも残らず
ローカンというのは生命のこと
一切の生命に一つも漏れることなく
一切の生命に対してメッターを実践している
そこでその心がチェータサ・ヴィプレーナ
私という感覚が潰れていくはずなんですよ
私私という感覚が みんな一緒の仲間やということで
自分の心がどんどん広げて
ヴィプラっていうのはすごく大きく巨大化になっている
ヴィプレーナ・マハッガテーナ
もう大きくなって 大になって
アッパマーナ・無料な心になってしまう
自分の気持ちが 自分という小さい気持ちがあまりにも大きくなって大きくなっていくと
アッパマーナ・無料なところになってしまう
それでアヴェーレーナ・アッビャーパッジェーナ
怒りなく 憎しみない心で
感情で パリッパ・アビヒャレティ
その感情は実感しながら
どんな生命に対しても
もう何のことなく自分の仲間やと気持ちがものすごく湧いてくる
どんな生命も漏れてない
あんたは仲間ではありませんということがまるっきりない
という この徹底した この何て言いますか
この差別心まるっきりない
全くの差別の差別がない気持ちを育てている
そういうのは理想でも観念でもないんですよ
ちゃんとやっちゃうと
心にその気持ちがちゃんと生まれてくるんですよ
だからちょっとした観念みたいな感じで
ちょっとしたもう一部もうちょっとした修行みたいなちょっとしたことをやっている感じでやったっても
これいうが何の意味もないので
こっちはお釈迦様本物の本気で言ってるんです
自分可愛いという気持ちがハッキリしてる気持ちでしょう
それがあまりも小さすぎて
で もっと屁理屈で他人が可愛くないってことになっちゃうんだから
もう法則も違反です 法則も破っているんだから
そんなもう不戦そのもの
で それで逆に善になるために
私はもうことは可愛いし
そのその生命もその自分のことは可愛いんではないかと
それからその相手の気持ちも自分の気持ちに映してみて感じて
それで同一視に感じてるね
な 幸福を幸せを願ってるんだよと
で 自我がもう消えてしまって
かなり無料な心っていうのは生まれてくるんです
エーバン バーギタイ コマーナ メッタイ チェート ヴィムッティヤ
そのように育てるとメッダーチェート ヴィムッティということを生まれるんですね
チェート ヴィムッティっていうのは心の解脱
だから慈悲でもって慈悲っていう気持ちを慈悲ではなくて
この場合友情ですね マイトリですね
マイトリという感情によって心はなんか解放されるんですよ
それは心解脱という書いているところなんですね
チェート ヴィムッティ
仏教のヴィムッティはパンニャー ヴィムッティ
智慧の慧解脱というんですね
だからこれもこの解脱に限りなく近い状態なんですよ
しかし 心に支えた解脱だから
やっぱり支えがあるんだからということで
仏教はもうちょっと支えのない
誰にも寄りかかることない解脱は正しいんだと
何かに支えているものを支えているものが消えちゃうと困りますね
でもこれは限りなく解脱に近い状態なんです
もう自我はもう機能しない
しかし 自我破ったのは心のおかげなんですね
心の気持ちを無量に無制限に広げちゃったんです
だから自分だけ存在するということじゃなくなっちゃったんです
その それは経験ですよ
ちゃんと経験することもできる
やん パマーナカタンカッマン
ナタンタトラアヴァシッサティ
ナタンタトラアワティッティ
パマーナカタンカッマン
これすごく訳はしにくいんですが
まあパマーナカタンカッマンっていうのは
本当はもうどんな行為でも
まあ一応制限リミットがありますけど
まあ制限リミットがあるように見える
その行為はその制限の中で止まるわけではありません
やっぱり人間という自分がやっていた気持ちだから
まあなんとなく制限あるようで
しかしそれだけでは止まりませんと
まあ一応実践の世界から言えば
やっぱり修行っていうのは
このある なんて言いますか
リミットがないと実際はできないんですね
だから 例えば慈悲の瞑想はその論理に則って作られているんですよ
私には幸福でありますよ
それはきちんとリミットがあるんですよ
はっきりしやすいんです
私が幸福になりますようにということだから
不幸になりたくないんだよと
自分の幸福だからね それは実感するんですよ
そこでリミット そのリミットで止まりません
やっぱり親しい人々 最初は全然感じない
しかしそれがいけない
いけないと思って どんどん親しい人々をみんなまとめて
あのリミットはもうちょっと別な
もうちょっと大きいリミットにする
だから実際伝統的にやる場合は
まず自分 それから自分の親しい人々
それから中立的な まあまあまあなんとか村人とかね
まあ知ってるとかね 別に例えば村にしたら
村の自分の親しい人々の親戚やらもう仲間だけでしょうし
もし大きい村だったらね
でもまあ知らない人でもいろいろ人がたくさん住んでいるんだから
まあみんなまあ中立的ですね
別に敵というわけでもないし
だからそんな感じで この中立的な
まあそれでも自分が何か知っている
知らないぐらいの もう半々ぐらいの人々入れるんですよ
もっとリミットが大きくなるんですね
それから嫌な人になるんですね
で 嫌な人になってくると
まあまたリミットが成り立ちますよ
嫌な人々って まあ自分から見て嫌な人だからね
やっぱりそれはまた結局は親しい人々になっちゃいますから
嫌な人っていうのは遠くいるわけじゃないんだからね
で それで自分の気持ちはもうちょっとしっかりするんですね
で だいたい敵 まあ敵という言葉
私に対して敵意を持ってる人々もみんなもう幸福であります
さらにリミットを広げていく
それで敵に対しても 何のことなく
もうちゃんと具体的に知ってるんだからね
誰が誰かってことで でも仲間で自分と同じだと感じたところで
まあでは全ての生命にやったらどうでしょうかということで
リミットを広げてしまうんですね
だからリミットで始めてリミットでは止まらないということなんです
それは実際 実践の世界の支えないと説明解読できないんですね
言葉だけでは だからリミットで始まる
リミットしてリミットして
ここまで頑張るぞ ここまで頑張るぞ
ここまで頑張るぞと それは実際のやり方なんですよ
そこでどんどんどんどん
ではここまでもやるぞということになる
だから 自然に進んでいるのです
いきなり生きとし生けるものがと言ったっても
まあその空の言葉で浮いていて
全然実感が出てこない
これは発見した心の実感ですから
ちゃんと具体的にやる必要があるんですね
それをお釈迦様はすごい簡単にパマーナカタンカマン
あのリミットされていること行為はそこで止まることではありませんよと言ったところはちょっとわかりにくいんですけど
実際はそういうやり方でやることなんです
言ってるのは それでたとえが出てきますから
セイヤタビマーナバラワサンカダモアッパカシラネーバチャトゥリサヴィンヤペーヤエーメーコーマーナエヴァンバビターメッターユテータユヌッティアヤンアッパマン
サマナガタンカマンメタンタトラワシサティメタンタトラワティクタティティ
まああのあれ あの法螺貝を吹ける人
ものすごい力強く法螺貝を吹ける人
力強い人が法螺貝を吹くと
吹くと 何のことなく いとも簡単に法螺貝を吹いてしまう
しかし その音はそれだけで
その法螺貝の中だけで止まってるわけじゃなくて
どこにでも広げていくいくと
そのようにもういとも簡単に自分の慈悲っていうのはすべての生命に広げていくんです
アヤンビコーブラフマナサハゲターブラフマナンサハゲターエマッゴ
これが梵天に生まれ変わるための道やと
梵我一如の道やと だからそういう梵我一如だったら
お釈迦様はまあいいんじゃないかと
人を差別する梵我一如っていうのはもうとんでもない
これは悪の道ということにするんですよ
言ってはないんですよ
だから本物の神がいるんだ
神は一人だけですよと
神は信じない連中はみんなもう処分されるよというところは
もう慈悲の一片もないし
いわゆるそういう絶対的な存在と一体になる道でもありません
だが その人はもう神でいるブラフマとどっちでもいいんで言うんだけど
それさえも知らない お釈迦様はよく知ってますよと
そういうすごい生命がいるんだよと
一人二人じゃな 結構いるんだよ
みんな知ってます かなり個人的に知っていたんだからね
それじゃダメで 一人一人の修行を知ってますよ
しかし 君もその世界に行きたければ
こういうやり方でやってください
それ一つ慈悲メッタ 二番目ポナチャパランマーナビクカルナーサハゲテーナケーサ
カルナーですね 二番目
憐れみの心 助けてあげたいという心
何とかしてあげたいということ
だから まず自分から始めて
自分の弱みなんかはなくしたいとかね
自分のいけないところはなんとかしたいとかね
で そうやって自分に対してのあの憐れみの心でちゃんと感じてみて
自分が病気になったら必死ではないかとか
お腹がすいたら必死ではないかとかね
寒くなったら体を温めるために必死ではないかとかね
心が体が汚れたらそれを綺麗にするためにね
いかに慎重でしょうかとかね
そういうところを自分の弱みをなくそうと頑張って
それはみんなに同じですよと
ある日 熱海で朝ごはんを食べている間に
ものすごいかっこ悪い鳥でしたけど
かっこ悪いっていうのはそんな綺麗な鳥ではなくてね
なんとか泥色でというか
黒いでもないんですね
汚れたこの枯れた葉っぱの色で
まあ桜の木たくさんあるよ
そこへ行って座って体の手入れするんですね
丹念に あのすごい厳密に
1本1本のあれなんて羽をね
一つ一つ羽もちょっとそれぐらいちょっと長いんだから
一つ一つくちばしで持って
こちらもやって上もやって
それで次のものを持って
結構ね かっこね あまりにもすごく面白かったんで
別にかっこいいってことではないんだけど
やっぱり一生懸命体をきれいにする
それもちょっとなんとかなんとかではないんですね
随分丁寧に 翼はね 全部1本1本1本羽をやって
これで右に全部1本1本やって
これで尻尾も必要ですから
飛ぶ時はね まあそこら辺はまた頑張って
で もう結構時間かかったでしょうと
その前食事終わったんだからね
私はそれを見ながらご飯食べたんで
なんとなくすごい まあ楽しい世界というかね
まあどんな生命でもやっぱりまあそんなもんだなと
だからきれい好きっていうのは誰でもきれい好きっていうことなんで
ミミズもきれい好きなんですよ
ケムシも誰でもそれそれなりのきれい好きなんですよ
その環境変わったら生きていられませんから
だから人間勝手で ああ
これは気持ち悪い これが汚いとかっていうのは
それは成り立たないんです
例えば汚れたところで生きてる生命は
別な泥 泥の中で生きてる生命は
綺麗な水の中に入れちゃうとそれ死んじゃいますからね
だからきれいっていうのはそういう定義なんです
とにかくまず自分のことをね
自分の弱みやら欠陥やら欠点やら
悪いところは直したくて頑張って
その気持ちをみんなに同じプロセスでその気持ちを育ててる
一つずつやるのは 4つもやる必要はないんですね
どちらが自分にわかる一つですね
それでムディターですね
ムディターっていうのは喜ぶっていうことで
自分が何か成功すれば喜ぶ
服を着る時でもうまく決まっちゃうと
なんとなくあ うまく決まりましたと楽しいんですよ
料理したっても まあ期待通りうまくいっちゃうと
どこかで喜ぶんですね
楽しいんですよ だから人間には個人個人にはやっぱり成功を喜ぶということは確実にある
嫌なことじゃない こんなのは誰にでも同じことだと言って
誰の成功も喜ぶ 慈悲の瞑想
願うことを叶えられますようにしているのは
このムディターの瞑想なんですね
ウペッカー 捨の気持ち
それも同じく広げてみる
捨っていうのは やっぱりあまり感情なく平等に見る
どんな生命にも まあ楽しみもあって
悲しみもあって 成功もあって
失敗もあって まあ結局はもう苦労して生きているんではないかと
私にしても あれやこれやとかいろんなものがあって生きているもんやから
みんなそんなもんで だからこの冷静な気持ち
あんまり驚いたり 感情し・感動したりしない気持ちね
人生って苦もあるって楽もあるんだよと
これはすべての生命にも同じことで
ということで このウペッカーという気持ち育てるんですね
どちらにしたっても 無制限に無差別に広げなくちゃいけないんです
これ  4つの方法で何をやっても梵天に生まれ変わりますよ
それでまあ あの青年が聞きたかったことはちゃんと教えてあげたんですよ
それで一つ見えることは
このジヒキシャという 4つの瞑想はお釈迦様は仏教徒だけやってくださいっていうことにはしてないんですよ
涅槃解脱は仏教に興味がある人はだけやったっていいんですけど
やっぱり人間であるならば
もう誰でもこれをやらなくちゃあかんという立場なんですよ
だから宗教だったらジヒキシャでしかなり立てないんだよと
ジヒキシャを説いているならば
お釈迦様はそれを認めますね
ちゃんとした教えですよ
しかし チェートイムッチだから
シンゲダツだから 心で作るゲダツですから
心そのものは夢中だからね
困ったもんやと しかし
こうしたら単純な困ったもんじゃない
これ最高な境地であって
限りなく解脱に近い経験ですね
だからこれは仏教の瞑想というふうには紹介してないんです
宗教一般という 誰でも精神
宗教 精神世界がいいと思うならば
ジヒキシャやれと それで終わり
終了と 残りはないと やり残すこと何もないと
慈悲喜捨それで終わりということ
まとめてくれるんですよ
ブッダにしかできないんですよ
精神を育てなくちゃいけないと
心の世界や心の時代だと
これなんかくだらんこと言ったって
瀬戸内なんとかさんの説法を聞いたってもね
結局汚れるだけで終わっちゃいますからね
だからお釈迦様は全部まとめてくれてるんです
慈悲喜捨 エーバンゴッテー スボーマーノー トーデイヤクットゥー バガワンタン エータデーオーチェー
まあ彼がそれで感謝する
アビッカンタンボーゴータマ アビッカンタンボーゴータマ
まあとても素晴らしいと
セータイボーゴータマ ニックジタンワ ウックジェイジェ
あの口が下を向いているものは開けてる上に開けてくれるような感じで
パティッチャンナンワ ヴィーワレ
隠れているものはちゃんと出してくれるような感じで
ムーンラッサワ マッガンアーチって迷子になっている人に道案内するように
アンダカーレワ テーラパッジョータンダハーレヤ
暗闇に明るいよ灯火をあげるように
チャックマントー ルーパーニダッキンティーティ
目がある人には色が見えるように
そのようにお釈迦様がよくいろんな方法で教え説法してくれる
それはまあ定型文句で
いわゆるお釈迦様に感謝します
よくわかりましたと よく理解しましたという感謝の言葉は定型文句でいつでも言ってるんです
エーサーハン バワンタン ゴータマン サラナンガタム
やっと仏教徒になるんです
ですから 私はブッダに帰依しますと
ダンマンチェ ビックサンガンチェ
法とサンガに帰依しますと
アッジャタッゲ 今日からパーヌペータン
命ある限りサラナンガタン
命ある限り私は仏法僧に帰依しますと
だから仏教徒になることはいつでも自称ですよ
お釈迦様やるものじゃないんです
自分が仏教徒であるかないか
これ自分で自称で自分で決めなくちゃいけないんです
一言もお釈迦様言ってないんだから
この青年にも この教えは正しいんだから信じなさいよと一言も言ってないんです
それで最後にその人が納得いったら
自分自己責任で帰依するだけ
だからお釈迦様には束縛はないんです
お釈迦様はこの束縛 条件
契約は立てません では
あんた私のことを信じてくれるんだったら教えてあげるそうと
そういう契約を立ててるんだから
あんた私を信じて帰依するならば
解脱を体験させてあげるそうと
契約立ちちゃうんですよ
この人は出来が悪いんだったらどうしますかね
どうにもならんだから
ですから契約はなし 契約はあなたが決めて決めるんであって
あなた勝手に決めたらこちらがものすごい徹底的にやるぞっていう感じなんです
嫌だったら出ていいけど関係ないんだよと
入ったのは自分勝手ではないかと
入ったならば このようにやらなくちゃいけないというふうに厳しくするんですね
だから ですから サンケーはやっぱり自分の意思でやらなくてはいけないこと
仏教徒になるということ
それでハヌダニマヤンボーゴータマ ガッチャン バフビッチャン マヤン バウカラニーヤーチ
私は忙しいんだから帰りますよと
ヤサダントンマーノー カーラマンニャダ
いいですよと お釈迦様がこう言われる
アトコ
スボーマーノー トーデイクットゥー バゴウトゥー ガハキサン アビナンディットゥ アノーディッタ ウッターヤサ
ナ バガワンタン アビヤディッタ パダッキナン カッタ パッカアミ
やっとその人はお釈迦様の言葉を喜んで
お釈迦様の三回りを回ってお釈迦様に礼をして
もう帰還したいということですけどね
帰るんです テーナコーパナ サメナ ジャーヌッソーニ ブラ
ーフノー サッバセーテーナ ワラワービラテーナ サッバーッティア ネーヤーティ ディワーディワッサ
またあの大有名なブラマン人の一人
このトーディーヤさんのお父さんやらジャーヌッソーニといくこっからサーティとか何人か記憶に名前が出たんですよ
その出た一人なんです
ジャーヌッソーニというのは
あんまり有名で金持ちですよ
彼の特色はいつでも白い色で全部決める
単色で 服も馬も車も白い
それで馬につけるたすきですか？それも白い
車輪も白く塗っているんだそうです
屋根も白い それで屋根に吹いてる座る布団
なんとか座るものも全部白色で
全部白で真っ白で決まっちゃうんです
まあそんなの気持ちでしょうね
で 昼 サーワッティ街を出るんですよ
そこでジャーヌッソーニバラモンがこのスバンマーナワン
このスバ青年を見るんですね
遠くから来るの お釈迦様は街の中ではなくて
別の場所のところに行くんだからと
この街に住んでいたこのジャーヌッソーニが出ていて
あの人は遠くから来るの見るんです
విశ్వాసుభ
ం తోడైయ పుత్తం గేత్తదు హంద కుతోనుఖో భవం భారద్వాజో ఆగచ్ఛతి దివా దివాసితి
このすごい敬語を使ってるんです
このバーラッド王子君はどこからこの昼間どこへ出かけて帰っているところですかと ఇతిఖో
అహం భో ఆగచ్ఛామి సమణస్స గోతస్స సంతికాతಿ
私はもう釈尊のところから戻ってくるところですよと
తం కిం మన్యసి భవం భారద్వాజో
バーラッド王子君どう思いますか？と
సమణస్స గోతమస్స పంౄా వేయ్యత్తిం పండితో మన్యతి
あんたどう思いますかね？釈尊の知恵の方は
頭の方は 能力の方は あれ
パンディト賢者と言えますかね
あの人は 頭いい人ですかと聞くんですよ
これ知識人ですかと しっかりした能力ある人ですかと聞くんですね
答えるわけじゃないんだからね కోచాహం
భో కోజ సమణస్స గోతస్స పంౄా వేయ్యత్తిం జానిస్సామి
釈尊の能力範囲を説明するために私は何者ですかと
できるわけないよと 私のようなものに
సోపి నూనస్స తాది సోయో సమణస్స గోతస్స పంౄా వేయ్యత్తిం జానేయ్యతి
釈尊と同格の人でない限りは
あの能力はわからないんだよと
私に聞かれたって 同格の人だったらわかるでしょと
そこでこの人はఉలారాయ ఖలు భవం భారద్వాజో సమణం గోతమం పశంసయ పశంసయ
君はあまりにも褒めているのではないかと
釈迦様を 褒めすぎということですね కోచాహం
భో కోజ సమణం గోతమం పశంసిస్సామి పసత్త పసత్తోచ
釈尊褒めることもできんと
私には 釈尊を褒めてあげることさえもできないんだと
その能力はないんだよと
なぜならば 褒められている人々に褒められているんだと
సో భవం గోతమో సెత్తో దేవా మనుస్సాణ
もう人間のレベルも神々のレベルも超えているんだと
もう我々にはもう把握できる人ではありません
だってもう梵天っていうのはもうなんかあの例えから見るとなんかもう自分がもうあまりにも知りすぎという状態だから
もう神々の次元じゃないんですね
一人一人に聞いたっても知ってますよってことだから
梵天の神様について それで彼が内容を言うんです ఏకిమి
భో బ్రాహ్మణ పంచ ధమ్మే పౄాౄాపింతి పుణ్యస్స కిర్యాయ కుశలస్
స ఆరాధనాయ చిత్తస్స తే
సమణో గోతమో పరిక్కారే వదతి
我々バラモン人たちがすごい道徳だと教えているこの五つの法は
お釈迦様はただの道具だと言ってます
ただの心の道具だと教えていますよと
యదిదం చిత్తం అవేరం అభ్యాపజ్జం తస్స భావనాయ
怒りのない 憎しみのない心を育てるための道具に過ぎないんだよと言ってますよと
ですから 結局お釈迦様の教えはちゃんとやっぱり頭いいんですよ
この青年はまとめてちゃんと言うんです
ఏవం వుత్తే జానుస్సోని బ్రాహ్మణో సబ్బసేతా వలభీరత
だからオラフ行った それでバラモンがジャーンスニさんもジャーンスニさんがすごいこの
この出来事 この前もあったんですよ
他の人に会って話して
すぐお釈迦様のことを褒めちゃうと
この人はそれだけで納得いくんですよ
なんかちょっと で それ聞いただけで
ジャーナリストさんがすぐ車から降りて
しきたりによって自分が服を着てる上にかける服をちゃんと左肩にかけて
これは目上の人の前に着る方法なんですね
かけて お釈迦様いる方向を見て
手を合わせて合掌してこれを言うんですよ
ラーバランヨーパセーナディッサコーサラッサ
パセーナディッコーサラ王様には何のすごいありがたいんではないかと
大徳やと 王様が恵まれているんだよってことなんですね
なんてコーサラ王様が恵まれていることではないか
スラッダンラーバランヨーパセーナディッサコーサラッサヤッサヴィジテータタハガトーヴィヒャレティアラハンサッマサンブッダ
お釈迦様はほとんどコーサラ国に住んでいるということは
この王にとっては何という大徳でしょうかと
こんな人が国にいるとすごい力ですからね
ということで 経典が終わるのです
何の関係ない話ですけど
やっぱりこちらでこのジャーナリストさんの性格をちょっと出してるんですよ
なぜかというと 他の経典でジャーナリストさんがメインキャラクターで出るんですよ
だからそこら辺を合わせるために
こいつはこんな性格なもんやとちょっとしたことで喜んで納得いくもんやと
それはやがてお釈迦様にさんざんもうやられるんだよという案なんです
そんな単純で納得するんじゃないよと
アホじゃないかと しっかりしなさいというところはすごく言われるんですよ
その他の経典があります
では 話をそこら辺で終了いたします
うん